yeah just took off running with the
puppy we are live welcome to the iron
Lords podcast episode number 38 it's
another glorious Sunday and we are back
at the roundtable on the Lord's Day
we've got two very special guests Paris
games week the eve of the Xbox one X and
of course that curse of Osiris DLC to
discuss so we're gonna get right into it
I want to introduce a Lord whose
opinions at multi-platform gaming I have
tremendous respect for in these Twitter
streets this Lord is a member of two
very respected podcasts and which is
critical and balanced thinking always
shine is super talented it's also my
fellow brother and I introducing the
senior writer / graphic designer of the
real games media podcast and panelists
of the basement radio arcade podcast
finally making his long-awaited ALP
debut love it
Lord Eric Jackson now you do accept
what's goin on everybody I got
goosebumps off that intro and when they
said unto me let me come into the House
of Lords big good follow on Twitter
y'all so make sure your father's
prevalent to it he's really good a lot
of good yeah real cool of course we have
a Lord who is no stranger to the ILP and
it's considered extended family at the
round table this Lord always fights the
good fight in these gaming streets
through the use of his amazing platform
with different opinions are encouraged
and real gaming discussions are promoted
in a very positive and constructive
light introducing the creator and host
of the basement radio arcade podcasts
the media bias and fanboy destroyer from
the golden era of the culture those
amazing arcades
Lord brat are we doing sir I am doing
fantastic I said I love that intro
fanboy destroyer Slayer was I feel like
I was walking down the aisle excited to
be back on the Isle or podcast you guys
you know much love I really enjoyed what
you guys do you guys one of my favorite
podcast also I'll give a big shout out
to add it cuz he's helped me a lot on
destiny even though I haven't been on
recently on destiny and big shout to to
channel 5 those destiny in like two
weeks brat back in the building
the good fellas are here exacts we just
missing be money he's the live chat I
think that's a so yeah I know we gotta
get be money back over together that's
the holy and of course we have the usual
suspects at the round table
my co-host with the cult most my brother
from another mother and the howl of the
wolf mommy
Lord addict how are we doing sir sorry
I'm this last week
I know you weren't doing good dreamcast
got missed you man he really did good
gaming Lord the solo game will list with
a single player selfish experience
consistent online switch profile this
week rapid Lord sovereign how we doing
sir fantastic great we're counting down
and Counting dad I don't know if
everybody knows what I do but what I'm
about to get a new console in the house
I clean the house of course the excess
gamer the lord of combat sports who is a
man of his convictions it demands
nothing less than the premium experience
be love it more King yesterday New York
City was on fire you have Barclays
Center rocking with boxing you have
matter screens Madison Square Garden
killing it with the UFC and it must
anticipated match said I wanted to see
I'm gonna do boxing real quick and I'm
gonna let my co-host for the Col most
jump in on this yo you see this crazy
yeah in a box and the televised cards
that you got a chance to see it was
three cards right and in the in the
first card you
the Russian cat versus the Japanese cat
right and me do it and and King King
done and I'm sorry I'm new to these
characters I've never seen them before
they gave me the most enthusiastic
spirited fight like four four unarmed
people if you fight I've ever seen it
was beautiful to see what's magic on the
floor um and then the next fight yeah
Shawn Porter versus Adrian granado's
that fight was big question do on your
timeline I got stretch through the
evening
this bout was anticipated because you
had Deontay Wilder the heavyweight WBC
heavyweight champion versus berman this
is Davern now Berman Suffern took
Deontay Wilder two years ago the
distance now ever since then Deontay
Wilder has been knocking people while
he's the only person that made it the
distance all right he that's how he got
his belt so this fight was anticipated
um now remember last week when I said
Anthony Joshua Florida bummer tomato can
he's lost the bond right so they're
trying to tell Deontay Wilder he needs
to fight more people to step up Deontay
Wilder is so upset he is so angry as a
champion because he's not getting to
respect the respect that is due our
American champion our American champion
did the most disrespectful knock out of
a man between that in one realm he
obliterated Behrman stubborn I'm talking
about that's the best knock out I've
seen of a man he lady spoiled him out
with his legs cocked back and its arms
giving it up and [ __ ] he just submitted
to the man see money in a chest while
there's a straight
I'm affair whoever can do that to
another main role every lesson follow me
look and look like a crime scene chalk
outline he was fantastic yeah it's we
had so many title fights titles changed
hands a lot of dominant champions came
back I got a shout out to ohm TJ
Dillashaw he put my man Cody Cody to
sleep you know I mean I was surprised by
that I'm a big Cody fan no love man he
got caught out there man Cody got caught
and I gotta give it up to TJ Dillashaw I
was one second one was Joanna female cop
away she is a soft but on yeah she she
got she got slept too by the side chick
Ron rolls
yeah she strikes
I never seen that long time so that was
funny and of course who I was talking
about the fight and I said listen under
normal circumstances GSP is would
destroy Michael Bisping
and no matter in whatever he's just that
talent he was to go when it goes before
he left
but four years off you know the game has
changed you buy this guy he's fighting a
bigger guy he came out that he looked
good he had Freddie Roach from boxing in
his corner
you know the boxing was tight and then
once he got him down
I have to admit though Gila he looked a
little round I mean and I noticed that
he was little wind adjuster I don't know
if you gets it round three out of the
egg because you got more like muscle
people to get like you says having when
you put on all that muscle we got to see
how you doing round two round three late
round see you was not trying to hit it
so shout out to GSP main combat sports
I was definitely definitely real fun if
you missed that car check that card out
it was a vintage UFC car I'm glad to see
I'm addressing the things because braaap
is in the chat and prep can understand
we grew up in an era where we went down
to the arcade and we challenged the the
best we put our quarter up there why
while he was peak knocking people out
street fighter who's like here let's do
it um and we lose a draw yo we was like
yo good one
catch you later we go back hauling our
skills and another arcade come back to
the champ see the champ on another time
on what I've noticed with this new crowd
these weirdos y'all are scared to take
the loss you're scared to get out of
your boxing you're living vicariously
through others be the hero of your own
story don't tell somebody else's story
tell your story don't let another man
bring you down by you feeling that you
were riding his coattails ride your
coattails
thanks and I say that to say this the
fakes and the phonies out there I know
you I see you and I curb y'all put you
the side if I tell you I miss you with
that I miss you with that because that's
exactly how it is a man challenged me
and I took that challenge you set the
parameters and I didn't kid
cuz I'm a lord and King so I stepped up
to the plate no loss and if your heart
left with that then your heart need to
go with that because
it was basically a brotherly bet between
my brother and you know another man
jumping and I respect his hustle I
respect his gangster and I love the fact
that he jumped in and he put his face
out there and he was just like yo I'm
down with that smoke too and I said yeah
I accept your challenge
all the way to the end I'm holding out
let the pain go that way cuz I thought
it was uh gonna be a different situation
but I say we accept every challenge
because we are born like that you guys
you know really because a lot of people
listen to our podcast and I don't want
y'all to be afraid to go and challenge
yourself via individual be different
don't follow to walk away from we don't
get this thing started with courses law
here spread neck gaming realness on the
ILP
not on you what you want to hear though
what you need to hear so you know it's
great when you back at
round table you know all the good stuffs
going down so you know we want to get
into what the Lord's are playing but
before we do that and says Lord rap has
already been to this chamber with the
Lord's an ILP 26 do y'all history new
ILP fans I want to start with Lord
Erichs video game system history and of
course what led him to the podcast game
were both rgm and so uh Lord Eric first
systems you started with brother oh man
my very first system was the Atari 2600
you know definitely the kid many hours
into that and then that led into never
had a master system but my cousin did so
I used to rock on that but so Sega was
in the roots but my first was the NES
Rob and so you had the decade with yet
devoured Madison I was looking for my
Rob a couple of years ago and kind of
found my mother gave it away like um
because I want to put them on my desk at
work I was like I was hurting over this
I hit some crazy prices but that's not
gonna happen so I got the little amiibo
acidy the whole yogurt so in there from
there you know I definitely had the
Genesis does yeah I took a little bit of
a hiatus you know like as a kid you know
got into sports you know that's that a
lot more I kind of took like a little
bit of a lull but from gaming for a bit
and then I came back hard with like
saturn and dreamcast and everything like
that
yeah that's run time started making my
own money so it was fired ago now back
up one second after the UM the NES you
didn't jump into the Super Nintendo was
that kind of okay good Super Nintendo
uh but I wasn't playing as much like I
had a you know so my collection of SNES
wasn't his B and then actually what got
kind of like took me away from gaming a
little bit too is I had two NES like I
said with everything right mmm my game
collection was fit and then our house is
broken into
everything wiped out my mother mother
provide and no and actually one day if I
made a few years ago I said a couple
years ago I was reading an article you
know by Colin over are you he went back
and you know kind of highlighted gaming
with inflation like what the systems
would cost back then to what it calls
now yeah I stopped for a minute I was
like no thank you thank you thank you
single mother single income you made it
sex with no joke how much that joint
call us brand-new man you know I'm
saying so so bad
Genesis and then from there you know I
was rocking by my own stuff rocking
bachelor hardcore was definitely like
the ps1 brought it back because I was
the oldest on college I was working oh
and I just remember like being up you
know to like 4:00 in the morning 5:00 in
the morning having me go to work playing
with my cousin falling asleep yeah but
it came back hard for life from
Dreamcast ps1 on it was some give me
some ps1 games that was rocket give me
some ps1 games but the one that brought
me really back in later why thank you
okay perfect pain it's just a believable
Oh bro it was what what what you had the
arcade was what you had in the house say
that exact exact them so the day I'm
just trying to think back through all my
ps1 joints arm it's classic
of course on the drop link right now I'm
thinking about you already made some
plastics on me did you play topo number
one because that's my favorite
PlayStation one system game of all time
Asus was that was that it was that scum
square in um ko it was joint it was
square and it was like a curatorial I
don't know exactly who it was in
conjunction with it was somebody else
they partnered with but it was an
amazing you know guess what we don't
keep one of my favorite Sony systems
somebody look up Tobal number one tell
us whole square partnered with yeah we
got to find out yard I was a classic man
ps1 classic factory n square so with
devoting like that was it but I mean
again it was just designs by by Toriyama
finish up oh no I'm saying I'm like like
it's funny how gaming takes changed this
back then already rocky mush with like
turn around but the respect is there now
like I said that's the beautiful part of
it back now is never too late
history looks good good thing I was
always curious about it and like I said
it's very certified I seen a lot of
classics being mentioned so we respect
that and then real quick as far as the
um what kind of led you into the
podcasting obviously you want to two of
my favorite podcasts you know say
alright and of course the rap in the
building themselves so
so that's thought no doubt yeah my first
foray into podcasting was with miss
Bella rise you know Bella back then it
was EXL number one we emerged into the
RG I'm thing to an excel podcast and
doing the developer podcast while we
were talking about industry people and
stuff like that so that was like my very
first podcast catch it and then from
there where we can hear you know
approached me about when you starting up
you know the base of radio RK podcast
just hit me up one day which was you
know huge honor you don't say because I
was like at that point it's kind of like
you're running around Twitter you know
here and there be no cool people and
stuff but ask me to kind of come on as a
guest nice history with that and then
bouncing back and forth between you know
our GM and brat let me hear to now some
of the Lord's theories you know like as
far as Twitter and podcast and goes you
know try to keep it real say well you
know what I want to say but but not be
disrespectful people you know saying
because anyway it's like yeah I try not
to like a clown and I'll you know that's
what people take it as you know I'm
saying like I don't hate on any system I
don't want anybody wants to play anybody
wants to rock on but I will do for
people who I call that the brat about
you know because I'm at the end a day
one thing I do respect is that even
though you may not be a fan of something
you don't hate on other people's
happiness or enjoyment of whatever that
is and that's why I said you know what I
respect that brother because it's hard I
notice in this culture that they you
know I may not be a fan of whatever John
wrong whatever you know system but if
I'm seeing a group of people having so
much enjoyment I'm like you know what
shout out to them you know be broke and
I see you kind of mean you mirror that
so always will you shut you out fat you
know
and Brad - of question absolutely play
it let's see something if you get
twisted about it I'm coming at I'm gonna
move on you say should twist you up on
what you love you can there's nothing
anybody can say that will take away the
enjoyment exactly let somebody do that
you deserve to be who's dong I lost
relationships over Saturdays a group of
men could just be in the house playing
games for 12 hours well you know I I've
only been playing Wolfenstein the new
Colossus and wow did you copy really
doesn't exist until November 7th both
are very very good games
this is the best Wolfie that I played
and
for me to see and I don't want to spoil
if anyone has a play but the way they've
kind of developed beating flash was
character in this game is just awesome I
mean and I and I come from you know
playing the original Wolfenstein on the
PC back in the early 90s it's I would
say BJ's probably one of the better
written characters today
now considering his origins I believe
you got me in the game of the year
it could be Game of the Year I'm telling
you he said
iconic character when it comes to
first-person shooters and like he and I
like I was expecting him to kind of or I
should say not him but the developers to
kind of just feed that stereotype of
this you know like Duke Nukem type
character this big size on a bra and
he's just running and shooting people
but there's so much depth him as a
character in this game that it really
breaks a lot of those stereotypes and
that me is like the the brilliance
behind this game and I'm telling you
it's anchor said it could it sits up
there for me Game of the Year right now
you shut up I'm gonna shut up you brat
because you anchor shot the more
Dreamcast guy last week you guys are
selling me man
and now Eric you know he's telling what
air telling me like I can't wait you
know I'm on my premium mole with like
low key I just I just want it at its
finest I had you know they're like okay
60 all the bells and whistles all the
trimmings the extra sauce
look you for what you guys are saying
I'm really excited so that's that's good
to hear ya know it's you guys are you
guys are gonna enjoy it and I just want
to say one quick thing about Mario
Odyssey attenders got another game of
the Year contender now a cruise and I'm
taking my time taking it all in and as
far as like the premium experience know
that yeah I was like the melon show
where I'm gonna get a X but I already
know that I will play this game game on
both systems dope as I'm playing it on
PlayStation right now but but the one
thing I will say and I've seen anchor
out there kind of talking about did you
I don't know if I'll put them over
Naughty Dog's and although this has like
that pedigree right now but machinegames
has been taking notes yes and they they
came with major character development in
his game and I'm talking about 30
minutes in you're gonna be like I
connect water for now in a way that I
didn't connect with him at all or before
he was just like you know a protagonist
now he has a soul and now he's a
character well I'm saying I mean he has
that heart and just this way this story
tugs at your heartstrings
noodles with like cook issues that we're
dealing with right now in this country
this game is not maybe trying to be
their voice but a deli and he has that
definitely you feel that tone is very
timely nice that's why I'm here I
suppose playing that Wolfie kind of
low-key
what are we paying for next week mm-hmm
to be honest with you nothing I played
everything I want to play this year oh
that's that kids me sharing laughing so
you touched you touched you finished up
shadow of war yep that's all I really
want to play I tried I tried Assassin's
Creed I just can't get into it and maybe
you'll see an emphasis he didn't get he
got to get a switchback right nothing
we're anticipating for the November
that's it we good for you I think I want
to go back and play the the expansion
for ex-con but besides that that's about
all you get that it what is it called
diem I know just don't curse at X Isles
or whatever it is they got a stop $40
asking for dollars though that's
ridiculous but uh anyway dude though the
big money's coming at you full hate you
notice a screen shout out the Santo
Berdych at Lord saw what do we play a
lot of Mario man nearly three hundred
moons and and I'm just I'm just kidding
I'm in a snow level right now so I mean
I mean I've been staying as long as I
can on the level it's getting all the
moons and I know there's something you
can't get to you finish the game so but
I'm trying to get as many as I can and
just having a blast with it the game is
fantastic and it's just waiting just
excited to play Wolfenstein
Assassin's Creed on Tuesday of and just
and and get into some of the back compat
stuff and see how that stuff looks max
no doubt looking when we playing this
week hey yo you know I'm playing destiny
I had to leave that clan that I was in
because any time the rhetoric is gonna
be destiny is dead I don't want to be a
part of your clan night falls to raves I
help all those who need help I'll II
need help if you got ways to show me how
to do things I'm constantly learning in
that game and I can't not learn enough
from that game so no it's not dead for
me I'm sorry I made a hundred now to
purchase I'm gonna rock that game
playing Mario Mario I got I gotta give
it to you guys I'm really nervous about
the good good lately - hey so 1.7 they
sold 1.7 million in three days that's
the fastest selling Mario ever the only
thing I held on to that's the only thing
but I'm thinking about what's the stuff
they not saying though is galaxy like I
I expected like a thought but so much
more so much more these guys are Master
Craftsmen when it comes to their
franchises it's a beautiful
very vibrant game when you got a shout
out the Lord King when I came through he
had it on that 85 inch whatever I'm just
like Aunt Mary looking like this and he
loves even more this Lord's house is
something new I just come here to get
the premium scraps that's what I come
obviously if y'all follow my Twitter
tournament shout out to this is the
police game crazy
so shoot or type weed racial issues more
like morality choices of it I'm addicted
but yeah B I touch Mary o lightly we're
going back and forth with that but on
yeah it's all about prepping and
prepping for the X and we get out there
looking for Chrome and getting that set
up I'm a ps4 pro getting together trying
to download some classics but I had you
know getting ready so we gonna get into
this poll that we had from last week
poll results of any people spoken to the
question of the October 27th murderers
role of gaming which is Mario
Wolfenstein Assassin's Creed which
combination will finish higher and
highest in October MPD the winner at 76%
in dominant fashion is the Muriel
Odyssey and Assassin's Creed origin
combo coming in second at 18 percent was
the Mario in Wolfenstein combo coming in
at non-competitive six percent origins
ed Wolfenstein combo so thanks to
everyone who participated in last week's
poll what do the Lord's think about this
it felt like it would be sort of the odd
man out and just
Trio just because you know Assassin's
Creed is appeals to so many different
people and it's been gone for a year
they've been telling all these changes
and of course Mario we haven't seen a
new open world Mario in a lot of years
so obviously that was gonna do well so
yeah but to be honest I did feel that
Wolfenstein was gonna rate higher than
assassin's creed um and it is overall
not not by a lot but it definitely is um
so it's just one of those things where I
think this is what's gonna propel
Wolfenstein to even greater heights just
because all the word of mouth that
people were talking about talking about
this game it feels like it feels kind of
like the Godfather to like it's part two
of a trilogy and it's it's fantastic I
don't even want to know how they're
gonna finish off the trilogy but it made
sense it made that that would fall to
the wayside a little bit doped Oh Lord
brap what do you feel about that uh
result I mean I'm not surprised I mean I
thought I mean I was a surprise no
results at all I mean I think you know
with the SAS inscri like I think there's
probably more anticipation - I think
sovereign said because you know it you
know they take they took about what two
years or a year off the game mmm so I
think there's there's definitely more
hype and I think anticipation for this
game especially given you know
everything that happened after
Assassin's Creed unity it wasn't a bad
game a guy I've yeah likes any city kids
like like Erica actually put me on city
kid he's like oh man it's actually
really good and he was like say a lot of
people slept tonight and it is good I
bet played I've played a probably a
couple hours of the game I haven't
finished it but it's definitely better
than unity but you know I'm not
surprised by the results I think you
know Mario obviously I think there's a
lot of there's a lot of hype behind
Nintendo right now and Mario and I just
wanted to say something regarding the
Nintendo switch I think I may have said
it on all the first time I was on this
podcast when I said they're gonna take
holiday and PD that's right
they might do that we look we had we had
Matt piscatella on this past one
they use a hash whose industry analyst
for MPD and II you remember man he said
what'd he say he's gonna have his
prediction for next year is this
switches got out so Sony and Microsoft
Wow now he's going Matt is going through
2020 18 he's talking 2018 is projecting
this to outsell both PlayStation 4 and
Xbox
Wow Reggie was saying it was like 16 mil
but he's not I mean they they're doing
it there dude bro I guess I really do
like those polls you guys drop every
week though trying to get to try to get
the post of the people you know and
start to be money to tell you that I'm
giving over to be money every time and I
shot him out every time he said it
though you didn't waver you put it out
there it seems like they got the right
formula so uh yeah that was the poll so
seems like the people have spoken we got
a new poll cooking up at the UM end of
the show so I stay tuned for that so
let's get into these topics Shelby I
like some nice topics at the roundtable
no it's off what's been going on and
Patti what's been happening definitely
doing something so last week they had
their Paris newsweek presentation and I
just wanted to get the Lord's feeling on
on what they felt so when he talked
about their they're excited not excited
I mean obviously obviously look on Ito's
excited because he's back into
PlayStation honestly Lord you know has
told me for a while
yo I'm gonna have to come through and
get one of those pros disdain you know
for picking up the machine that I have
they forced me to play
he told me a minute ago and he knew I
was gonna make a move with these exes
coming out and he was like let's go
he hardly comes to but his car was in
their driveway I mean so from my
perspective I honestly see this becoming
Sony's big show in a lot of ways because
if you look at e3 the past few years
they're really reluctant to really go in
and announce brand new stuff triple-a
stuff at e3 they're gonna give you
gameplay and stuff that you expect for
the end of the year maybe some maybe
some some gameplay trailers of stuff
that are coming for the following year
early on maybe first quarter but usually
Games week is where they give you more
in detail gameplay for stuff that's
coming out at the beginning of the
following year and into the end of that
year and it just feels like this it is
more substance to it um and it kind of
makes me wonder what they're gonna do
with PSX because PSX the same thing it's
like that they may announce one or two
things that may be a couple of years
down the line hopefully we'll be getting
some release dates for like spider-man
forgot war stuff like that that people
are expecting but I don't see it I don't
see it being a big announcement show so
this one felt like it was a big
announcement show um so honestly I'm
impressed with them I talked about how
they follow this same formula all the
time for their triple-a game so this
third-person over-the-shoulder
action-adventure with RPG elements and
loot elements and you you know whip it
up in a blender put a different skin on
it and boom you got a winner the fact of
the matter is that they do
I mean I'm excite an exactly what
they're giving me and I'm excited to
play it i.e so I can't fault anybody
fulfill it that way the triple-a stuff
looks fantastic I like the fact that in
the pre the pre show they double down on
the indie stuff I think they made a big
mistake kind of downplaying Indies when
it was just a sign that they were going
back to that that hubris that kind of
got them in trouble in the ps3 era and
the fact that they shot they shot down
the Indies that helped them so much at
the launch of the PS
so it was exciting to see them come back
and talk about spelunky to talk about
guacamole - and a couple of cool new
games that are coming out um they had
the Hong Kong massacre the concrete
genies kind of like a home it looks like
like like stranglehold from the 360 days
but man mm-hmm
so I'm glad to doubling down on that
stuff I honestly to be honest I really
don't want to play those games on a ps4
so hopefully they make their way to
because lately I think it's twitch is
such a perfect platform for it so it's
hard for me to play indie games on like
my home consoles kind of thing but I
would you say no they they looked real
good absolutely did and then they double
down on the VR and I'm happy for that
because again we've we've had issues
with Sony we had issues not supporting
their parental roles whatever roles
exactly now always support their primary
system but if they're you know they're
they're their portable system or any
other peripheral they drop if it's not
selling the way they feel it should it
dies man Jeff real quick once I shout
out the Lord King really pioneering and
champion the VR movement on an ILP we've
been let we was clowning him who's
laughing he rode it all the way and I'm
not even front whatever that little
English British gangster game if they
got light into here but it you know it
looked and they got another one with the
little mouse with the knife or whatever
good I was very impressed out Jay Bari
as well we were talking not too far
along but I gotta give you guys credit
you guys been kind near an area and they
look like they're still committed to it
and that's always good to us yeah yeah
absolutely I think that's that's the
best thing about it that you can and
you're seeing more
full-on games as opposed to experiences
which i think is what was worrying
people about this I
am I just gonna get these either half
our experiences and they're gonna be
charging me an arm and a leg for as
opposed to the full-on game so I'm glad
to see this is coming through the blood
and truth looks fantastic it reminds me
of the getaway and James Bond and it
just I I heard I think Greg Miller was
talking with uh with the Giant Bomb guys
about like little things that he was
able to do in the demo will I keep
something whether I think like a grenade
at him and he just reacted to the
grenade in front of him grabbed it with
his hands and threw it back and it and
it worked so this is something like that
that line where where VR sort of becomes
this this second nature thing where
things are happening and you're not even
thinking about it
it's starting to improve to the point
where the experiences are really on
another level and at nad and to me
that's a positive thing and to see them
at the forefront of that is fantastic
it's an optical to their triple-a stuff
and they double down on a lot of stuff
we've seen before they actually showed
us some more footage of Detroit which we
all found to be fantastic at e3
they showed kind of a controversial
scene where it shows of a childhood
Houston and whatnot this murder they
went in they showed more the saddle of
the Colossus
they showed more of the God of War and
to me the big one the big one we've all
been waiting to see
Oh besides the last of us too and the
controversy behind that we all know
about that looking Last of Us - still
looking fantastic
um but Sucker Punch has been kind of
m.i.a for quite some time people didn't
know they would come out with and we
have ghosts of Tsushima looks oh my lord
talked about piecemealing
cap cons IP and we brought up on a
moonship is not having you know the
zombie zombie stuff in it just the
setting alone the feudal Japan setting
is what that's a huge alien samurai
maimie whatever I don't care what
happens going on
the fact that they're taking a realistic
approach to it kind of and and the fact
that it's it's a samurai basically
that's forced to sort of leave behind
his Creed in order to protect his land
and he's gonna walk that line between
samurai and ninja
that is crazy I got ten shoe vibes oh my
lord did it get tension vibes on what do
you say that's my heart ring I was the
bride
I brought tension oh my lord when
everybody jaw dropped to the floor we
started playing at tension we just when
he got his first little murder on from
the sneaky yo we stopped everybody you
know we went out to go get our Chinese
food
so this is amateur hour right at this
time we from everybody's eating he's
playing this game we didn't care back in
the day we would play these games we
didn't know what the menu said we didn't
know what no what was doing to get those
vibes so in this game I think it's just
perfect and it and it goes back to what
we said about Sony we can say whatever
we want about Sony and and how you know
how they announce games five years in
advance and that's how they they get
over because they keep people excited
but the stuff
stuff takes forever to come out but it
actually it does come out they hardly
cancel anything so I mean they've
perfected this formula and they just
continue to deliver on it and it the
fact that you're getting people back
into the fold that left to full proves
it like they just they they're very good
at what they do they're very good at
promoting their games and showing their
games in the best light to get people
excited and it's something that I don't
think Microsoft does nearly as well
this to be honest man I'm excited I'm
excited for what 2018 brings can i
interject something real quick - oh man
you got to jump in where it goes this
machine was deserted one of the first
things I saw people saying well it's a
CGI we didn't really see anything and if
you cannot play sucker punch in a second
son oh yeah you would be hard-pressed to
go from what was CGI and that to the
actual gameplay so you have a proven
developer working on something you can
almost kind of bit what is what you're
looking at in this CGI no throwing up
air clothes
it's not gonna eat pretty close to what
some of the gameplay is gonna yeah so I
don't know why in this culture we had
this thing to see the light start down
playing as opposed to being excited I
come here summer talk about it he'd be
excited yeah what's more exciting
do you remember they've been working on
this game for three years this game
nearly done guys it's it's not two years
out this game is almost done right can I
am okay I want to interject for a quick
if I get all frylock breath um so this
is and I and I said this on our DM last
night II may remember my little rant
Cognito oh yeah I thought you know Sony
a Sony show it was I thought it was
pretty good for the most part I mean
obviously there was a lot of footage
things that we saw from I guess from a
triple-a perspective a games already
knew about obviously sucker punch was
like the new the new franchise but uh
you know I think for me it was like a
reminder that any remind you of my
biggest frustration with Microsoft right
now that when we hear things like
you know and I and I get the equity the
economics of game development have
changed you know we hear you know first
party games are more challenging to make
or triple a big first party big
budgeting games are harder to make now
blah blah blah you know and then and
then we see a game like this from Sucker
Punch right and we see games like
Wolfenstein coming out but don't have a
multiplayer aspect to it but more we're
more important like with sucker punch
like you know they could have come out
and done another infamous right you do
that they've called it completely gone
in a different direction a new IP a new
story a new character and this is what
Sony does so much better than Microsoft
mmm and it's my biggest frustration with
Microsoft because if I look back at cut
previous console generations and and
look I'm not saying it's to pick on
Microsoft I I want I say because I want
him to do well right I want him to look
they got the hardware down now we've got
the services down now the only thing
they're missing is that software piece
with with with respect to first party
stuff Master Chief is great but I'm kind
of over Master Chief gears is great but
I'm getting tired of gears for to over
the Big Mac it's shaken fries that is
that what you say yeah I mean those
those franchises have become like the
like they think they've gone from being
McDonald's to McDowell's I mean it's
just I mean people look to be cross-eyed
I'm like oh you're just a soda fanboy no
is that nothing dude I'm actually a fan
of Microsoft I've I have a lot of
appreciation for what they've done for
the industry and in Eric you and I've
talked about this they always seem to
kind of be ahead of the puck in terms of
where the industry's going
they did it with the original Xbox
I remember they got hammered for putting
in an internal hard drive people like
well why that thing's gonna you know
he's gonna ruin it
yeah Airport they get hammer for Xbox
Live they get hammered for voice chat
but they're always ahead of the curve
but even back then to those consoles the
OG xbox in 360 you can always point to
specific titles that came out they were
exclusive to those platforms you could
always go back and think about oh wow
man like remember that game ever when
tears dropped remember when the first
halo drop when we popped in halo for the
first time in the OG xbox and you and
that music came on we don't know we
don't have that on the Xbox one mmm we
don't have that with all sincerity oh oh
hell Phil Phil gamer pickup feeling it
you love them all right okay when it
comes to this man and I'm truly
believing in buying and the cool except
I drink the kool-aid when I was there I
honestly believe and I'm seeing him
systematically changed the narrative and
I know he has those games that you're
talking about in the stash and when they
start the hit they're gonna come and
they're gonna come with full force cuz
he got his system it's not a weird
Xbox one he took the ball out of these
guys quote right all right he's giving
us pride back when she was still pride
in the crowd then you could rally the
crowd he they took a game that they
could have pushed out I thought like
Sony was gonna do spider-man and push it
out right and just because the
capitalize on the spider-man movie or
the blu-ray but it didn't come out I was
surprised
yeah what surprise spider-man did not
launch around the time of homecoming the
movie
I mean they would use them as an
opportunity marketing opportunity and
and once Microsoft decided to push back
crackdown because it didn't receive that
level of enthusiasm that they felt was
warring it with the title and they
wanted to be a success and they pushed
it back I said okay they were on that
path that braaap is talking about
they're on that path of bringing back to
fundamentals and that enthusiasm back to
the games I believe but you know sorry
interrupting breath but III know exactly
I got share the same frustration I want
them to do well and I noticed a Sony is
is killing it when it comes to
absolutely a shout-out to the chat real
quick because I see calendar hey and
listen we hear what you're saying like I
mean first of all Cal is going ha he's
like so we give a Sony too much credit
you have to give them credit because
their we'll think about this we all we
hear more recently is the the economics
of game development how expensive it is
how how big triple a single player games
aren't revenue generators anymore you
know how you know games as a service is
a future we hear about all these these
different changes in terms of ways to
generate revenue in the business you you
have to give Sony credit for taking
creative chances and for allowing if
people who are creating this content to
take those chances I mean you can't you
can't still say we're giving him too
much credit no we're giving him enough
credit because they're taking these
chances to create these these phenomenal
gaming experiences that they don't
always work out you know I think he's
only even said you know you know for
three to four out of ten of the games
they put out that are exclusive or
profitable you know and make money for
them but the point is is that they allow
their studios to try different things I
mean you go back to you know guerrilla
games going from Killzone 2 creating
horizon zero dawn which is a complete
180 anything they've ever done before
yeah you know I think I think part of
what what comments is there is that at
the core they're not the most fun games
to play and to a certain extent like
some certain games I can't be honest
like I go to uncharted for the
characters mmm and the grandeur of the
game that the tech showpiece that it is
I realize it playing uncharted isn't the
greatest and it's never been it's
improved steadily from game to game but
it's still not the best in terms of
cover shooting couch does have a good
point
you said they only dog Verizon and GT
this year mmm
he said they're heavily reliant on
third-party like I mean yeah I just
wanted I want to comment on something I
came and said and he's saying like I'm
you know we giving him credit but Jesus
Christ he's trying to hear about what
xbox sux and we're gonna get into that
with the whole you know when I get into
the next segment but but what I want to
focus on is that at the end of the game
what's being presented is it getting you
excited is it something that you want to
play if you honestly are walking away
from these from Paris games week and
saying that none of that stuff interests
you they don't power to you you know I'm
saying like that's not for you but the
consensus seems to feel that hey like
what this show it looks good when it
comes down to it's like look like they
are relying that you know they have you
know persona stuff like that and this
year would have been so bad if you know
these games that they put you know all
this faith into suck but this year
almost every game they put faith into
was you know hit home runs it's not that
it's not the fact that you know that
it's inspected they rely on those games
it's the fact that for the most part
games like Nier automata games like neo
neo games like he'll play like these
games are pursued by Microsoft it seems
like so it gives them that edge right I
think that's the only game Microsoft
couldn't a gone regardless what happened
right well if you look at those other
games
you know obviously there was deals that
was brought up get that but it's like if
you could could have took those you know
those will call them guns if you would
have took those guns out of Sony's
Arsenal what what was Sony have had this
year they would have had persona 5
horizon and GT but but since it looks
like they didn't really try to get these
games because a lot of these are
Japanese orientated games and Microsoft
has had you know the we haven't seen
them really pursue these kind of games
that much in the past couple years they
had a hell blade they had Nier automata
like one after another we I mean we
could very well see these games on xbox
next year I mean Phil is constantly
talked about his trips in Japan and
described is made in that he hasn't said
anything but again we've always said
he's gun-shy to talk about stuff to
these a hundred percent certain it is an
actual game or it is actually gonna have
yeah callous clarifying nothing he says
not he's not saying that what they
saying miss Zhong is not great he's just
saying that as far as Sony's first part
that's his specification he's saying
first party isn't it I thought that
their Paris game show was indicative of
how Sony feels about the ex oh that's
what I'm talking this is the point I'm
saying like the aggressiveness and
keeping on the neck we all know the ex
is coming right what we do get
aggressive they put it back in the
mindset of hey we're still here this is
the we got games what are we doing this
which enough the narrative man Microsoft
is like it's like they planted a ballet
dancer Microsoft can't catch the steps
this play every time they feel that they
got something all right we got the
resolution baby
what
it's almost like it's planned perfectly
because if you look at all the x1x
reviews coming out now right they say
they're situated perfectly right after
the Paris games week so everybody who
reviews the X right most people have
said you know what hardware-wise this is
a fantastic leap forward but looking at
looking at Sony's Paris games week the
beta for Xbox and game exactly and I've
seen it in people's written reviews for
the X where this stuff seeps in is like
well if you look at Paris games week
that's where the issue with Xbox lies
and now it's just a narrative whether we
believe it or not that's what I mean
that's what's been portrayed my take on
the show was and I saw some
controversial things I saw some
beautiful things I saw competition at
its finest and I'm pretty sure that they
drew up away they said well how do you
will we want to approach this man they
was looking at the narrative it actually
said well you know Phil came out punch
this in the mouth let's go punch fill in
the mouth the brutality and the level of
content that they were showing like I
really honestly I'm timid I'm not gonna
put that out there I'm not gonna put
that you'll you will get the game and
find out that this child murder in it
later
yeah Detroit would be kind of like also
a fuse and the Last of Us with the arm
you know hanging women and feminists
feeling away and emotion that it brought
out it's just your trailer without a
date they give you trailers without
dates but they control the narrative
because you're talking about this days
after and you like you know did you see
like if you go to wrong way the child
dies
but I honestly love the competition
standpoint is they're gonna push this
industry forward they're necessary evils
with each other
Nintendo's the wild card Nintendo's
doing things that we don't even think
that they're supposed to be doing with a
700 pieces about them trying to sneakily
get in there and kind of you know they
have they have a Xenoblade direct coming
on the 7 here is the you know the map
that everyone else does okay
how much does that cost okay this cost
that much we don't need all that okay we
just need this this it's like but you
know that's like a lot of these features
is like been here snare thousand five
they don't care about that okay we be
this this and this so argues me go make
the system as you build it they will
come
I watch how my kids I swear I could be
playing destiny whatever my kids walk
path in there whatever I put on the Sony
game I turn on that switch damn attic
they come downstairs enthusiastic why'd
I to figure out what's happening next
daddy you got kids
that's what I wrap this topic on are we
going we went a couple of 10s but um you
know I definitely hear what everyone's
saying you know I just thought all I
wanted to say I just want to give credit
where credit was due like I personally
thought it was a good
I thought it was a solid show you know
yes there were some things that we
already knew about or may have seen
before but I felt they showed more
extensive trailers I'm excited about
Detroit big time you know I'm really
excited about last of us to UM like you
said the VR games look pretty oddly the
gangster one looked pretty cool for me
and I just thought it was a good counter
to try to take a little Thunder away
because we all know the exes coming and
I just compared standpoint that's what
you need to do like you need to get
because let's be honest it from if
you're a Sony guy right and you don't
have an xbox and you know the Xbox one X
is coming you know as a fan of that
console you're gonna feel away okay what
do we have kind of thing and I felt it
was perfect timing to just to get online
feedback to give this their own base
confidence coming in like you guys are
good for 2018 we talked about real quick
what does everybody feel about god water
gotta what trailer my boy thing I was
talking too much
I understand giving giving cradles more
depths and making him more of a
character and the narrative part I have
a feeling they're gonna do fantastic
with that the gameplay number yeah
combat looks kind of like a play on what
they used to do and a lot of people
wouldn't let that combat but mashie I'm
telling you like ever since the Last of
Us was made they're like the same thing
okay let's take a zombie apocalypse
world or the last of the earth I know
you go take a war game throw the Last of
Us form a daughter it's like look like I
get it it's cool the last was did well
that gameplay is generally it's key to
the hardcore it generally gets a lot of
the hardcore to buy their game so
usually does decent but it's like come
on man like let's be real here like yeah
like you know I get we go after
Microsoft for like you know the the halo
the gears in the Forza
but is it okay for Sony to make the same
game with different
will you break down the gameplay
mechanics games they're not on saying
though
oh come on of Canada's eine like you
know open world design but they break
down the game mechanics though I would
be okay but we go from a game that had a
previous trilogy they changed that
entirely around so too until I was
visual because we didn't get a chance to
touch it let's give him them a little
bit of the benefited I'm still sitting
with decline I know but I fried I don't
know what Atticus said and I was praying
that it wasn't that you know I saw the
Last of Us 2 and I was just like yeah
yeah that looks like the last of us with
God wall and I'm not I'm not doing that
I don't want that I really want that
flow to feel that cradles that
overpowering beasts and I don't know I
don't get it from it yet but also
remember they notice they show fire and
and they was putting out their other
stuff for you to see so I guess I
thought that was filler a little bit
column B coming together because yeah I
think what they're doing is answering
you this is this has been my issue and
I'm not trying to go back and say we're
bashing Microsoft but I said I think
Halo and Gears have value this property
I just think you need to kind of like
reinvent them a little bit and kind of
mimic forward because I think Keith and
Marcus and I and I said this before to
you know some people coming back at me
killer they should market you the
guiding gears for mm-hmm
let's move it forward you know saying
and but I think chief and Marcus are
holdouts from their time period the same
way I think they play those if you had
Kratos in there right now and this is
happening with ascension ascension did
not do well because I think people kind
of getting kind of tired of all right we
get it
Kratos is pissed off the guys screwed
it's almost like Kratos is Twitter let's
let's be real let it go
the Kratos in this game wasn't too far
off from the cradles from the other
games okay well I mean
calm down so he still don't care about
anyone else's life but his cell no I get
that but I'm saying
when I was playing ascension I was
sitting there I was kind of bored but I
was like I'm coming in to the point
where I'm like I'm tired I don't know
what's gonna happen with this new god of
war but I can see that's why say there's
a column a column B you got last of us
feel and it's true
Sony could be playing a slippery slope
with kind of following the aesthetic
with all their games but in a way
they're saying okay that kind of worked
let's see what we can do at least
they're trying something new whether
they fall in their face with it at least
they're pushing something like a
different aesthetic we I kind of feel
like Last of Us and unchartered Jack
aspects from God of War like you know
the UH the interactive cutscenes that
are chartered in like doing that way
back on the start comparing first-person
shooters to every the origin of every
first two Wolfenstein yes well you don't
know but that's not that's not uncommon
I mean game developers borrow ideas from
yon steps it's whether or not they
execute those concept yeah so overall I
mean we were assuming the Lord's but
we're pretty okay with and I'm up to bat
so we had the G reveal
so we got our console launch exclusive
on xbox our preview program is gonna be
December 12 so right in the middle of
the month you know that pub G's gonna be
there now I'm swimming it's gonna be a
digital code in the box and it looks
like they're gonna get up they're gonna
launch 1.0 version of hub G with in
conjunction with the PC version so um
definitely you know excited about that
and I'm definitely excited that you know
public G has a release date it's a huge
exclusive you know regards how anybody
feels about the game personally and you
know happy let's give it credit it's one
of the fastest-growing games on PC it
looks you know as far as you know the
mind share it has it's the current mind
share right now everyone's going crazy
seems to be the new wave what I wanted
to comment on was something that I saw
going on during the reveal we're gonna
read only for the simple fact that um I
didn't see too many people talking about
it now no arm shout out to Brad please
enjoy he was on my Twitter timeline
during the time when we were both kind
of watching reveal at the same time and
this is us at the iron Lords podcast no
all I'm saying is this you know we just
talked about the Sony Paris games week
and we just talked about how we felt
from a competitive standpoint that that
was a good counter to try to take a
little dündar away from the X cuz we
know that X is coming we got digital
foundry dropping people getting those
you know review systems they're getting
the games you know more and more a lot
of positive stuff about small yada-yada
were getting that with addict time
the thing that I've noticed was that
okay so for me obviously Xbox is my
preference I want to see what
quote-on-quote
the home team is going to do after Seoul
era show was a good solid show for the
most part
so no it starts out in right off the
back these technical issues issues you
know the mics don't work no credit is
that greenies fault no you know is it
one of those situations where this has
never happened in the history of press
conferences and games no but all I'm
saying is it just feels indicative of
the year
Microsoft is having in 2017 it's more a
fix on that they've had actually called
that you know 2070 for Microsoft the
year of the L as far as from the
exclusive standpoint things like this
and this was that there one thing to not
botch like you you got pub G exclusive
or your platform why your mics not
working why is the the showcase of the
demo of the game now I get it
might not be the greatest game to demo
it's a game based on tension it's like
The Hunger Games hundred people drop
into you know in Ireland and it's a very
tense thing but it seems that when it
comes to presentation this is where
Microsoft is a little bit behind Sony
and I just want them to work on it
because in my opinion this is me
speaking that type of a presentation
when you're having oh that's
unacceptable to me you cannot have that
you cannot be fumbling over the mic you
it took so much thunder away from the
December 12th get now feel like okay
yeah it was supposed to be a great
announcement so I'm done with my rent I
know I'm gonna get the Microsoft again
comments though but I gotta keep it 100
and a lot of a lot of you guys you know
shout-out to my people on Twitter and
stuff like that I just felt the way cuz
y'all know that conference was not
displayed right I'm a fan of the
platform but don't let's not try to act
like dang bumbling fumble that whole
situation
I know what they were doing don't you
they were giving a foreshadow like oh
you know what you know why understood
was also watching a show at the same
time I really can't I can't I can't
believe that I can give these guys
chances on top of chances and they think
they're nice at free styling I've come
to this this assessment then Sony writes
down their stuff they hit they written
they walk it out they go over to show a
million times and it comes to make sense
of it right and again I know I'm an
emotional bond but I'll try to make
sense do you think he just has something
to do with the fact that Sony comes from
that movie you know studio background
either as they just know how to present
yeah actually yeah that's right Eric
shavers blackly said that on a podcast
he said that because I think it was it
was T XR when he XR was around they were
talking about the whole Sony like how
Sony lets their first party tried new
things and he's like look he goes it
comes down to the end of the day that
Sony's been in the music business
they've been in the movie business they
get it they freestyle rapping
it's not going well okay is not supposed
to be presented like those that's again
that you showing trailers you saw the
exciting parts it's too much those
points for that game to be shown like
somebody laying in the corner waiting
for you to walk past that you can play
on one match for like ten hours don't
move a muscle eating a potato chip dango
all right so and people are trying to
figure out what's this the Microsoft
wants to be so hip so trendy so Twitter
so new let's do it off the riff we've
got guys that know stop it stop it write
it down that's less let's follow the
script let's do the formula now let's
get it done III was disgusted with the
show I said I I took a me
I took literally physically took a me
and say yes sovereign in my head your
sovereign um one and I saw that the game
wasn't ready I said it looks like for
tonight might beat it to the show late
for tonight might actually get out
before them and then I hit it crap it's
actually technically out now this is
crazy but I hate his crap that they said
that the game comes out in December 12th
right but at the end of the month is
gonna roll out all official despite me
he actually was on my timeline during
this whole you know the whole pub G
announcement so I want to get your
perspective on that yeah oh god you know
III agreed with everything what you said
the man has a mic why is his mic not
working maybe sick like thing of any
presentation right I guess is to have a
a mic that works but I agree with you me
like I was like I was I was shaking my
head because I kept thinking like we saw
the crack down footage at was it San
Diego comic-con that what happened I
didn't think it let me tell you
something Larry herpes is major Nelson's
great he handled out like a pro he
really did we need to talk about the
skeleton in the room to how they go show
the pub G trailer from ether I'm gonna
be called a hater I'm gonna be new
trailer for Gamescom Lord King said
another guy camping carrying around a
thumb drive in his wallet with all the
trailers one of these that's what I said
you feel like it sounds like they're
phoning it in like whatever you should I
mean it should be that thing where you
just like it should be pyrotechnics
going off REE Berk should walked out
like the Nature Boy Ric Flair with a
robe you know I could see doing so you
say Brad like that you're finish it off
you know I mean what else are they gonna
show though I mean like the game is
pretty much
I mean it's a it's a it's a an arena
game I get that they can't show much but
then something else besides this [ __ ]
they already showed yeah that's true
they can it's like a tournament it's
like a games called why'd they show
fours the seventh sank trailer for me
three
well yeah oh they could get it even like
let's be constructive but they could've
even showed the cooperative or cuz isn't
there a more than pub G where you can
play teams as opposed to the chicken
dinner everybody by themselves kind of
thing like a shout out to be money I
understand your point it is a tough game
all I'm saying is that try something
different use the same
of kills right at the point of being
shot or whatever
it's not the fact that this game is not
hard to show it's the fact that the
moment you show something you've already
showed it a previous event you've lost
the audience you think you've lost the
audience that's like spitting the same
lyrics again no you were forward we know
what's gonna happen we know to do with
the pot when they say stuff like oh you
know I think that uh this game just hard
to show let them show that same trailer
again at e3 and see how many people were
coming around with torches yeah I would
have loved them to show that like four
key talked about the Xbox with X
improvements talk about what 40s you've
got so many other things you can talk
about and still make the announcement
and avoid the thing but I'm gonna let me
get it to Lordaeron law solving them but
you guys feel because I'm going
beyond a feeling second all day
now like I said before I just feel at
times like again you know you'll get
hate for saying I just feel like they
like they phoned it in just like kind of
light with Gamescom kind of light with
this it's a sort of light like we can
you get people excited if you don't seem
like you're exciting yourself at times
and it seems like every time I mean they
don't have an answer for something it's
like no hostage do they knew everybody
was there to wait to order you know for
the pre-orders to go live your answer
can be just you know the Beast
II real quick man who's the actor
because I brought up staining your
comic-con member when they put Larry her
about their Major Nelson he's and he had
her like a pro boots guy stuck the
controller's nose or the mic or whatever
okay this thing just went left you just
put the mic in his nose and home girl
came back and grabbed it and put it next
time out on Mike at that segment
Major Nelson was off-camera so you'll
get back to talking to Phil and he's
going off now saying you know like you
know by you know Forex is real people
are looking forward to it but it seems
like anytime that there is there's no
answer for something else and people you
know other gamers 100 other thing that's
always it comes back to the X and it's
late you know it can't be like the
answer for everything this you have a
whole world of gamers want different
things can't be the answer to everything
is because what are they gonna do after
the 7th like the ends is out like right
right and I think I asked I veto the
song on clear to new I said you know do
you think in some cases they really like
an only answer to like their Twitter
based this my every move that they make
is an answer
so what the Twitter base is in the world
right yeah I mean it's one of those
things I think listen you know it may be
one of those things that Phil is looking
at the long-term game and I still that
respect to film me they is just one of
those things where it may have to say
you know what guys this is the situation
we're in in 2017 this is the roadmap
you know we're limited as far as what we
can do to scale about consolation
whatever whatever you know we know the
systems come in as far as the Xbox one
next we're gonna promote that heavy we
got pub G that's our big thing you know
the kana and I just think that it just
see if I think the vibe I'm getting is
like 2018 a year they probably really
can do stuff but you know for the for
the base that's acting like everything
in 27:17 was late no it's not me call me
bash in and because the fact of the
matter is you know you guys rock with
Xbox I rock last generation that 360 was
like pretty much my premier platform I
didn't get a ps3 on July 3 years name
because they were talking their
craziness told I could tell you for like
I don't sit there and play with
corporation because in all this all been
hurt then they were given Xbox is true
you know media they said something
disparaging about us but I could make it
up because it's business and you should
learn a lesson on this it's not what you
finally have to say something about
what's down the pipeline
you can't tell me that you know a year
and a half two years into whatever it is
that you're working I'm gonna look for
know about you know what's gonna get an
asset III don't you go down to 2018 will
be better because they're coming off
from the basement I mean let's let's
look at you know to our 2018 okay they
got SATA decay they showed it really bad
at e3 they really show anything that
made people want to grow grass to that
game this might one of my most hyped
games to they did okay correct I can see
that they showed in 2018 that you know
they showed it good is see a thief's ed
III that's the only game because I feel
like crackdown got destroyed by its
presentation it's soda stated okay but
transition to your topic which is uh the
Xbox one X what addict look let's let's
get into listen switch gears just see
how we can change this thing around and
let's see what's was actually popping
right now so better so we better make
this topic quick because we got 15
minutes so the X obviously coming out in
two days what what is first off what's
the first game you guys are playing
because I'm curious by that Oh stealing
the poll question okay let's get let's
get to guess let's get a lot Bradlaugh a
lot Eric let's get them in well that's
wrong you
not only is King David in with this you
know who's winning November those things
that unless you have the forecasting
you're not gonna see a so unfortunate
because you know saying that is
unfortunate because I can say then you
can really differentiate you know me but
if you're looking at it on a standard
YouTube player that's what resolution is
in the 720 1080 P you
he's doing they're doing the the
side-by-side like I told I told you
where you come from but it's it's
definitely in effect but as far as oh I
want to get solved cuz I he's getting
he's getting x1 on one day one but
what's the UH what's the first kind of
thing you do you know when I first got a
game for me for me I always like to work
up from my lease you know the least
excitement that I have for a game to the
most excited the second game I'm gonna
I'm gonna hop in the gears and I want to
see what gears looks like I'll play a
stage of that or whatnot I see what that
is and then it'll be Wolfenstein and
then I'll probably finish off with
Assassin's Creed that'll be and I have
the week off so I'm going it's like that
we go yeah Widow I'm sorry for you
finish or something I'll jump in after
yeah after that I'm just I want to check
all the back of that stuff and see how
that stuff runs and just kind of run run
the system to its paces and see if what
they talk about is true you know or
Cognito here the tech so for me
personally I just love technology and
anything else you don't know what get to
you know honestly is more so to push
this 4k TV purchase that I had from last
year because I was kind of future future
proofing myself and for when the ex came
in the pro and stuff like that so no not
I got that in place you always want that
medium that's gonna show off that TV you
let that medium that's gonna push it you
know to the next level for as far as me
you know obviously you guys been talking
about wolfie what that wolf was down to
so bad but if the Apaches ready I'm
probably going to jump it's probably be
like what look except I'm gonna do
assasin screed I just want to see the
difference is I want to see you know
their 4k goodness see what that's
looking like you know as far as and also
I want to push a lot of native 4k games
I'm gonna jump in gears for I actually
um held off shouts a second chat
actually held all four gears for there's
a couple of games I've held off I have
not played in my back one years for was
one of them
purpose which is re all in the PC gamers
waiting for [ __ ] I got like a lot of
stuff I'm looking at my you know i
refresh my I go on my xbox storage i
refresh the UM the Xbox one the hands
list and I keep seeing things at it a
low fives on the list I want to see
what's going on you know and for me
personally and I don't think this gets
enough credit is halo Master Chief
collection because I always love what
the vision for that game was supposed to
be we all know when but you know I'm so
excited to see that they didn't abandon
it you know I mean and to actually go
back put 4k assets and the functional
like I must I'm such a halo fanboy from
the classic standpoint to actually see
what they can do on the Exile I'm
excited about that so I got like a
couple of things I'm gonna put it
through the paces and like I said if
it's up to me but des des if you got
that patch Lord income in your chest
speak to God how would speak to a
machine game whoever you need to speak
to because I need that native forte so
as far as that the non XP quotes are
machine will AB rap I think let's go
bring it back to attic so what is it
going to take for you to get excited or
is there any particular thing that you
want to see the ex do to get you guys on
the train
not really I mean it's it's nothing
against people who want to get it you
know but it's just like I got an S that
plays the same game I don't got a 4k
display so why would I go out and buy
that - what if they secretly dropped the
Destiny to pads for 1080 60 I kinda
bought the argument last night shoutout
to a bell in any of the guys over there
it was my question was again for the
people on the fence were like hey I
don't have 4k TV what if they now offer
these performance modes like they're
doing with gears I
raisa Tomb Raider like Lord Airacobra
with that let's go there because I kind
of brought this to let Brad last night
so um you know with that kind of entice
you like let's just say they had you
know destined to was announced at 60
frames per second patch at 1080p or I
know art actually has 1080p 60 as more
than X enhancement would that kind of
rule you a little bit Lord I don't know
um right now is I'm pretty much I'm
almost there you know I'm saying but
what I'm kind of waiting on is the
impressions from like people that you
guys like I don't trust the shells you
can't really take what they want your
games to play this don't matter their
minds gonna trick them don't take my
word for it let's say they play an
assassin's creed let's say you know
theoretically they're like oh I don't
see huge huge difference
they it suddenly minds of like nah
there's a difference look right there
difference difference I would do its
difference difference difference why are
you upset that we're waiting dolby atmos
we have the equipment to maximize like
we got destiny we got things to play to
hold us down you know me it's just extra
stuff to play that we wanna see I don't
know I couldn't wait okay like people
that are
for these games they weren't really
really waiting for these games you're
trying to tell me I don't understand
what you're saying you don't understand
me I pay 10 grand for my tell ok so to
making sure my eggs is maximizing this
so those games I don't want to see them
in they subpar form listen listen you
don't get it because Microsoft put a 4k
screen up there they could've put a
regular screen up there they wanted you
to see it in its real form I want to
play it how they intended it hey Brad
yep
true/false if they put if Assassin's
Creed origin comes out let's say these
games they want to say this right it's
only a couple of days to be honest with
you to wait for those games
destiny was months this is a couple of
game yeah I would have waited inside I'm
a wolfenstein head I'm even more of an
assassin's Creed head you know how
difficult it has been for a week to have
your games on my hard drive and not
touch them I haven't told Cognito
yesterday I was considering cracking for
a little bit tomorrow so I get to see
the difference between what the S looks
like and what the exits like later on I
mean honestly I mean these are games
that I didn't love I absolutely devoured
the old blood and the new order on every
accessions create I've said this a bunch
of times on this podcast I will clean
the map out in an assassin's Creed game
like that's how I play those games so to
have that back and not touch it if I'm
be honest must which has me held that's
all just about to say that's why show me
that's the point I was trying to get
across Anakin I understand his sentiment
his sentiment is okay you guys really
ain't that excited for that game super
exactly but the difference the
difference now is that the way the
culture is now we've got so many
triple-a title games to play
I can literally bury myself in Mario
Odyssey and be fine I'm saying I'm this
is the police y'all and I can't stop
playing it so it's not that these games
are not hot it's just that I have other
distractions to hold me for that then
I'm good and the last one is when you're
a tech head right it's a different
mentality you know as a tech you want
the newest the hottest the latest that's
always been my mentality if you if you
know that there's something out there
that may perform a little better you
just want to see how much better right
you just want to see what it Nats them
in town I think that's the part that I
because the disconnect was because his
thing is like a if the games is hot I'm
getting it you know I'm saying I feel
nothing I'm not waiting six months out
like if that were the case I would wait
I would have not touched Gears of War at
all I wouldn't do the Gears of War
campaign and I'm
and I'll go through it again those
things play you know the game came on in
such close proximity to the tool onto
the system that I just said look I'm not
I'm not gonna do it
that's it but I'm super excited for the
super I can play those games on PC I can
literally play it probably better
looking that he's been on Xbox one else
a buddy the thing that will probably and
I totally reek and be this like I want
to share what he was saying in the chat
just now you can say Mikey messing to
step up the first party for e jumps in
and we've talked about that I kind of
felt the same way I know inter said the
same thing and I said the one thing that
will push me is being a you know I took
part in the game stop flip a few months
ago I'm gonna have the credit the thing
that would make me jump and this is
gonna sound crazy
GameStop does that same thing they just
did with the ps4 you know I got the
Destiny Pro bundle I had no intentions
of buying a pro so but I couldn't resist
that they were giving me two hundred and
fifteen dollars for an OG ps4 oh no they
let that flip that's right now they own
a stand if you pre-order yeah like a
hundred fifty one hundred something
towards the Xbox one I think they gave
me with two or one for my xbox one SS so
like the day of when I'm switching it
over gonna put them in the boxes that's
like 110 dollars so to be like the same
thing like I have no problem switching
it out when you see but it would be that
thing and keep our eye out for the flips
of
you brats telling him yesterday
because he was like he wanted to buy all
the games all at one time I said oh
Peter it out like get the one that you
really want to get first but we all know
target at this time in the year has the
buy two get one free always of all the
hottest games every year and they do it
two weeks before Black Friday so I'm
like yo before that comes out you can
get a couple of those games for free and
if you get the digital codes because now
they're selling you know they're like
the digital codes for the games and that
will equate to the same thing I'm just
going to cuz he you know he wants the
whole digital library just gonna pick up
you know two of those cards and get a
card for free and you save so much money
this holiday season and all these games
that you really want it by not running
out and purchasing them day one and by
waiting so closer to Black Friday
there's so much money the point in the
backlog is there and in the fact that
matter is we got Black Friday on deck
so with those games as well we could be
seeing discounts so again that's why I'm
Wolfie is like wait if I don't hear
anything
I still got enough stuff to play the
whole moon for about two to three weeks
Black Friday combo let's see what's
going on when they do those holiday
sales that xbox is known to do those
digital sales right you know they're
gonna have their Black Friday digital
lit as well so you know what all's on
the wait and see totally understand
mentality cuz I have a feeling my s
values without a plummet one watch to
say I can't say for sure but I'd be
wonder because yeah there was a point
that like OGX boxes were like you walk
in the best buddy $75 it just reminds me
Lord grep of a funny mean I saw on
Twitter and it's like as a Gamestop
employee and a guy has his whole arcade
collection everything stops like yeah so
that'll be 750
it's like game stuff be like wasps you
know get a twelve-year-old in the pocket
bring it just dig up we got you up one
curse of Osiris baby talk to me yeah all
right um so we saw you know bungees
livestream and um I wanted to know
because everybody I don't like the
rhetoric that's surrounding the game um
you know people are telling me that
there's nothing to do that the game is
dead there's nobody's playing and this
is what happens when you panned it to
the casual crowd this is the
conversation that you're gonna get when
a casual crowd is no longer enthused
they're gonna move on to so many nice
new games that are out right now all
right
um and my thing is will those casuals
come back when this DLC drops cuz I'm so
height from what they show from the
exotics to the lore to the OP I wanna
know more about Osiris I've never wanted
to know more about one character and my
whole life like I watched the trailer
like a million times
looking at the ghost I'm like pausing
the screen looking at stuff like oh
that's that gun that's was born I like
I'm doing it and never thought I'd do it
but I wanted to know how many people is
excited oh well that crowd come back
well we get these people back
well the millions come back when it
wants to DLC come out how many people
purchased the game with the DLC and is
forced to come back the validate they
purchase come curious I do done I'm
actually high for Cyrus cuz first of all
he's geared everything like we talked
about this on an rgm yeah and by the way
King I agree with you it's it this games
not dead
I don't understand people say it you say
it's probably casuals wouldn't but yeah
I'd like I'm just when I saw they where
I saw the trailer and what I liked about
Osiris is that like we don't know too
much about him we know a little bit
about him who he is but he was like his
outfit and everything
it faded to that that need that you have
a destiny xur to get new items it made
me think I need that and that's that's
part of the lore destiny but um I'm
excited for it I liked his um his ghost
to go so much different from like the
regular ghost looks like he was kind of
like almost of somebody's gonna be
piecemealed together a little bit but
like all he has that like Native
American like vibe to him yeah he's kind
of like I got a little bit of like he's
got a little hood like on Assassin's
Creed he looks better
yeah all right so I'm excited I can't
wait for it I'm excited but that's where
people say like oh you know destiny
there's nothing going on but you notice
that with because that was the same
thing I heard last for destiny one you
notice what when the dlc comes out
everyone comes back to it that's a good
point
that the girl comes back to it now if
anybody could get a shout out for their
marketing team its bunch like they know
how to market stuff in activism they got
that down for your good video sorry
no no breath I killed my character I had
an extra war life right and I killed it
I said me and rap is gonna I dream of me
and rap running through that aisle
running through time together building
our characters 305 right now like Bravo
well you know I I finally I finally
pulled the trigger got the the Xbox one
version right right and got on that got
got attic helped me out got me leveled
up and then Wolfie came out
casual but objects I've heard this name
of Cyrus since for such a long time now
yes you know we finally gets to meet the
the man I guess if you will let's get a
little bit Eric and Lorne Lorne attic
and you know away from it but we got
away from bring the ringer over so I'm
bringing sinister back to the foe oh
let's go let's go we meet them trials we
give them trowel like we like something
great for the cleaner you know I've said
this before when he came to destiny one
like I was like kind of late and I kept
getting left out of the Ranger games
yeah so was it happening on Destin cube
another idea for me because I still get
in every week you know try to do my
weekly okay yeah you like you ready for
everything you know I'm Charlie ready
for everything I will not be left behind
I'm not gonna be again still let's fake
rusev oh I don't think the gameplay
mechanics the guns the way everything it
I mean this is Bungie they this is
crucible is just the closest thing I
think to perfection in I'm an online
multiplayer shooter yes yes therefore
before that tactical team trials for the
first
time this weekend and I got the fever
for the trials like I got the fever when
I was like okay we got three wins and
then we got that lost I was like ah what
do we do you say hit the strike button
take it away so we got a strike it's
busy Lord addict now that you've seen
the god Osiris how do you feel about
this deal it's gonna have it's gonna be
fun to actually play destiny to again
yeah I miss playing with you guys I
really do
in fact I mean I think what it what it
is to and I watch what I like with the
UM the live team now is jumping in is
that we've already got confirmation from
Bungie at this weekend punching that all
the stuff that the community complained
about with the end game
it came out with a bullet list of points
basically addressing it saying that
those would go live before the DLC so I
thought that was a positive sign for
that you know for hardcore guys that
have ended because for the most part rap
you know Erik Lora like we've we've got
we've got everything we want you know we
just want a little bit better rewards
for that pristine how many more times
the sins of the rocket launcher please
dad or how many times do I need to run
the Crispo for the same five draw how
many times do I need to run the strikes
for no exclusive gear you know what the
incentive for the people exactly so it's
so refreshing to see shout out to
Christopher Barrett and I'm saying shout
out to all my detainees guys they put
out the statement they listed an
extensive bullet point list of it pretty
much it was like everything we bitched
about list I don't see a problem in it I
don't like I actually enjoyed playing
other games why for me no attic it's
weird
it's like I'm so used to destiny taking
over my life that is weird like okay I
could cheat on you and talk to other
people
what would that speaks to though is the
strength of destinies community and
because your the incentive that you guys
took on was helping other people get
across the goal line
you guys got they call me or like I get
a message on I for got my boy he's
coming to I got you let's run it we
don't got stuff down the such a science
that it doesn't bother me to take twenty
minutes out let's run them through this
let's get him that Rat King that he
don't got you know little things that I
take a pure joy out of it because the
camaraderie of strong that I have the
most fun way to dislike me not attic
Lord King
most sinister and it's like when you've
run a person who hasn't completed the
raid for the first time that would be me
I haven't done the rage a Lord sovereign
mister offline or profile you know
saying because it is a certain joy
because it's like it's a brotherhood and
it's like this yeah we watched Nord
addict do them dogs and we smile I'm
like I'm gonna get some free stuff out
every day at least three to four times a
week consistently if not more he is to
this day the finest dog runner I've ever
seen give it up Lord at ago net nobody
won nobody means better then what act
this it's a fact I'll put my boy up
against any our YouTube streamers in the
Destiny can whoever you go to Buddha
don't it always whatever y'all cold
where it's all for them for the pleasure
God
don't stop me this bike running he runs
it like this is hard to explain it other
people are so scared and so ginger with
he runs it straight through it let's go
your list
it's basically real quick Lord aeroclub
rapping for their listeners I don't know
what the hell we're talking about it's a
it's a it's a stealth portion of the
raid it's the first time in the rave
that they have a stealth mechanic when
you can't be spotted by these beasts one
more the core they encounter in that's
hot in the prot with it's six of us four
of us on the ground we're in this forest
trying to be stealthy you have two
people up top Forest is foggy people
trying to help you out as much as you
can but you need one person to carry
this ball that's actually gonna give you
this these spores to help you through
the encounter and that's lured addicts
job and that was to be honest when the
raid came out we're getting stuck the
world the people trying to get the firt
world's first one they couldn't get past
the Pleasure Gardens so it's like to see
my boy out there and eat like I can't
run it with anyone else because they
don't spoil
I've had people [ __ ] at me say I'm
running too fast I may just slow down
I'll be like oh whatever you do stay
this [ __ ] we go wrap you could never
blame me because I'm always like look
stay with me stay stay in his pocket
Louis saw real quick before we wrap this
up what was your feeling of the curse of
osiris dlc did you get a chance to check
it out yeah yeah I mean like I said
before I mean I've fallen off and that's
partially due to Mario and partially not
being able to set aside the time that I
know I'm gonna need for the raid like
set aside the time to do it and then be
able to I know I can break it up during
the course of the week but then I don't
want to not be able to finish certain
parts of it and then get to the reset
and lose all that all that progress so
I'm like I just haven't been able to set
aside the time but that's what I have
left to do is to get that I still
haven't gotten a rat king
I need to do a nightfall and we gotta
get in that came five minutes listen he
knows right now soon as we get off for
this podcast I'm jumping on the
whatchamacallit and you know no problem
the problem is that I have wifey staring
at me since I'm off this week once I get
my initial touch with the ex on with we
will be doing that this week so no this
isn't destiny
they just can't say it I'm hearing it
there and enhancements are natural
there's no slowdown in public events
rate ports and that's not even official
patch that they've worked on yet so
imagine when they do actually make it
Xbox one and hits what the potential
could be would be interesting but we're
gonna wrap this thing up great shout out
the love breath we got one last poll
wrap it up it kind of stole the Thunder
from but anyway so it's gonna be with
the Xbox 1x launch just days away all
you day one adopted what is the first
type of title you will launch on your
shiny new X would it be a an older now
patched Xbox one X enhance title similar
to like a years a Halo 5 rise of the
Tomb Raider would it be be a brand-new
third-party game that's patch similar
Assassin's Creed Wolfenstein 2 or C
forget the game's 4k blu-ray Netflix
there's the question those are the
choices please Rock the Vote the IOP
Twitter polls when it goes up so let's
do these out rolls Lord Brad once again
an absolute pleasure always to have one
of
Goodfellas in the building nah man thank
you pleasures all mine I'm a big fan big
fan of the podcast love what you guys do
so keep doing your thing thank you so
much we're gonna find people find you
and tell us about that brat pockets yes
so uh brab based from New York a podcast
to go live every Wednesday night at 9:00
9:00 p.m. Eastern Standard Time so check
us out we actually in anticipation of
the release of the Xbox one X we
actually give away a free xbox one copy
of Assassin's Creed Wednesday to release
in ER yep drogon stop that and then for
the holidays we'll have some more
details coming up soon but we're gonna
be giving away a PlayStation 4 console
don't know yeah thanks for what our
listeners so keep an eye out for that if
you wanna get some more information
about braaap definitely give us a follow
you could follow me on twitter at braaap
we re p underscore podcast on twitter
and yeah definitely you know definitely
check us out we just be Eric Jackson's
be money we just like talking about
video games and having facts so to be
money as well yeah make sure you got a
support these guys real gaming talks
always a pleasure also catch that last
episode they had MPD's Matt piscatella
if you want to learn what you get your
educational industry works you pay
attention and you listen to them that
was a great segment good no doubt Lord
Eric a pleasure man it is David what you
for Lord uh you know this has been a
absolute honor a blast down Thanks you
know you guys for having me I'm always
willing to come through you know ya know
you guys are doing it being man this is
this is what's up
this is what the game community is about
you know you can have preferences but
you can also be cordial be cool just
have discussions you know I have to eat
it get it twist it a lot of times you
guys you know you get me through the gym
I'm sitting over that light laughing and
I know people think
no but no I'll rock with you guys no
matter what so definitely appreciate it
um find you oh yeah you can find me
Wednesday nights on Brad podcast you
find me running around Twitter you know
trying to be something of a voice of
reason but you know every now and again
you know put on one of your reason by me
Twitter ecj AXS a win you see Jackson
and also be sure to check out our GM
looking Mediacom game reviews news
impressionism ad rise and also our GM
podcast bi-weekly on youtube so yeah
check us out moon shout the same Tobit
in the chat we saw you maybe salute them
I like what you're doing great work man
all the time great articles good stuffs
that's doing - absolutely absolute
pleasure and of course my brother from
another mother
Lord addict was going or we can we find
you poppin pretty much Lord addict I ope
can follow me on all the gaming outlets
is bring to kill but steam steams gaming
addict and thanks everyone for coming
out no doubt no doubt
Lord sovereign the switch online profile
was late this week we're gonna find on
Twitter Lord saw P yeah big shot on
thanks to EJ and Lord Pratt you guys are
extended I of the family so when you
guys come it's not like it's really not
even guest man it's like they need to
build this like
I appreciate that we planted you guys I
was looking forward to today Piazza Oh
like it's always beautiful in your um
you know I got I got it this thing that
I'm trying to work on Kings in New York
all the podcasters that's in the local
area I want to do a visual type of thing
where we rent out a restaurant yeah we
could do a mob style you know we got a
round table talking about games and
stuff like that actual you know I got
the actual venue and stuff like that so
I'm trying to work it up chop it up and
see how much they're gonna charge us for
the you know space rented and the food
and stuff like that
but um I want that done and I wanna try
to get that as you know like a thing to
go viral for everybody to see like Tim
dogs Lords you know together as one
podcast community opposed to this
separate podcast sniping at each other
stuff that grows I that I don't like and
I think it'll be huge that we all have
is beautiful so you can catch me on
Twitter Instagram and Facebook division
is always there pushing and I am so
appreciative that you guys came through
and no matter what anybody thinks
my love for attic is immense so
absolutely if we joke around we play
around and I get under his skin he does
it to me sometimes
so listen don't don't don't think that I
don't have love for kick that I love for
the kid all things that's part of the
culture so a lot of people that don't
know us they like oh they they not gonna
be on the show then like an hour later
laughs it's just the competitive nature
and us being sinister like hey teacher
each other
you don't know us that's just where we
cut
from we go at each other and it just
still sharp and still you know
absolutely so again while kognito hear
the gaming realness was spread very
appreciative of our guests make sure you
guys hit that like subscribe to ILP on
all the inner circle needed network
media outlets we got that YouTube the
outings SoundCloud all that stuff will
be going up
still got that amazing tech GN patreon
and links in the description all the
support helps us we got some real cool
things cooking up make sure you support
us and like I said on that note we are
out we got some football to get to guys
oh my god go ahead no we out